- We're standin' here at the
Belarusian Ukrainian border.
Here, as you can see,
the Belarusians have set up barbed wire.
On the other side, just a
few meters away, is Ukraine,
and they have set up barricades.
The Belarus Ukraine border
has been a strategic location for Russia
since it invaded Ukraine a year ago
when Russian troops
mounted attacks from here.
Now, as Kyiv warned of a
renewed Russian offensive,
tensions along this 620 mile long frontier
are ratchetin' up,
renewing fears in Kyiv and the West
of a possible joint attack on Ukraine.
The Belarusian State Border Committee
invited us on a rare visit
to see what's happening here.
(speaks foreign language)
In recent weeks along this border,
Belarusian forces have been
holding joint combat drills
with Russian troops,
and on the other side,
Ukraine's military has
been reinforcing defenses.
The Border Patrol says that
there has been a lot of tension
at this particular border,
which is closed at the moment.
They say that sometimes drones fly over.
(drones buzz)
Ukrainian forces have
admitted to such activity
to monitor for potential new attacks.
(speaks foreign language)
Guards on the Belarusian side
are keepin' a close eye on the border.
Others are training to intercept
any unauthorized crossings.
(speaks foreign language)
Belarusian officials say
they think Ukraine may launch an attack.
Ukraine has dismissed this assertion.
(speaks foreign language)
Belarusian President Alexander Lukashenko,
an authoritarian ruler and a close ally
of Russian President Vladimir Putin
said in recent days that he
would again let Russian troops
use Belarus to launch attacks on Ukraine,
but he said he has no intention
of sending his own troops there,
though he warned of one
important exception.
(speaks foreign language)
Military action would likely come
with challenges for Lukashenko.
Belarus has a small army.
They are not tested, and moreover,
polls show that Belarusians do
not have an appetite for war.
But some Belarusians are
supporting Russia in other ways.
Here at the Belarusian Women's Union,
people have been gathering
boxes of donations,
of supplies, food, medicine,
for people in Donbas,
who they say are sufferin'
and need the help.
Vladimir Kazbanov is the Business Manager
of the Alexey Talai Foundation,
where volunteers work to send
supplies to pro-Russian parts
of Ukrainian's Eastern Donbas region.
(speaks foreign language)
Kazbanov and his colleagues say
they try to stay out of politics
and that the suffering of
the war transcends borders.
(speaks foreign language)
Lukashenko said that his country
is willing to offer more
assistance to "our Russian brother"
in the war against its
cross border neighbor,
but has dismissed claims by
Kyiv that Putin can pressure him
to take a more direct
role in the conflict.
(speaks foreign language)
(light music)